vous vous demandez parfois à quoi pense
aux animaux elle me manque tellement
j'ai oublié mon portable alors elle me
manque tellement de quoi il parle
ravi de vous rencontrer aujourd'hui et
ce qu'il fout quand vous n'êtes pas là
j'en ai s'agit oui j'ai plein de projets
j'ai un plan tout est détaillé m
il lui manque un boulon à la peluche
comme des bêtes
voici ce que font vos animaux quand vous
êtes la voix s'il faut quand vous n'êtes
pas là
la balade
la soie bien sale connard pas là
comme des bêtes cathy le blizzard
totalement irrationnel takavoir est le
chien le d'achat il ya deux catégories
de personnes n'ont pas plus tard neil
ceux qui aiment les chats c'est
impossible d'aimer un chat autant cacher
sans vouloir te vexer et ceux qui ont
tout faux si ça peut te faire plaisir
par les humains créateur de moi moche et
méchant comme des bêtes
c'est impossible d'aimer un chat autant
qu'un chef sans vouloir verser 100 %
tout faux il ya deux catégories de
personnes
à tout à l'heure louis a plus tard mail
ceux qui aiment les chiens on était vous
la tournée du doigt les bières compagnon
de l'homme et ceux qui ont tout faux car
si elle est bizarre totalement
irrationnel l1 chiant le dash ainsi pas
les humains créateur de moi moche et
méchant ça va les gars comme des bêtes